Praise be
to God, and prayers and peace be upon the Messenger of
God, and upon his family and companions and those who follow him, and may God’s peace and blessings be upon them
abundantly.
Oh my beloved
brothers,
spreading or exposing our committing
sin openly, committing
disobedience openly, and calling to evil
openly will bring about calamity and
punishment upon the Muslims.  God Almighty
mentioning
[Music]
evil great evil in
count non countries is haram a major sin
so
establishing first of all music is from
doing
which
hadith about those
mention will be overlooked
[Music]
sin except those who do haram and sin and
obedence openly so listening to music
like selling the music cd or doing the
music is haram as one of the said music
is the Quran of thean music is the Quran
of thean so we have to be  conscious my
de bless you all and we have to and it
and music that doesn't mean we are
extremist no we just following the Quran
the sunah we in the time when you start
enjoying good good and for the evil some
people call you extremist so to listen
to music you are moderate muslim music
is haram
as mentioned in the
inari wi other books they deem permissible
wealth permissible permissible
scholars from
God
excepting
God except by opposing by way of
opposing God his messenger to us to
enjoy the evil according  to the Quran
Sunnah, may God bless
you, very important some
people when he does the evil and
Participating in evil, calling people
to evil, when he sees evil in his own
country he remains silent about it, but if he sees
evil in a country which he dislikes he talks about it,
spreading it. And
we enjoy the good evil, Saud
algiaco,
however, enjoy the evil, accran and
bless all. Some
people do
theyed andadal
[music]
Hadith of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
If you speak out and if you are able,
hate with your heart and the lowest part of faith, so
this is the way to enjoy the good evil, not spreading it,
Subhanallah,
unless there is a bid and a person, unless there is evil and refute it,
as
we are going to explain if a leader falls
into evil or he allows evil in our countries, what is the way to deal with it
according to Sheikh Rabi, Sheikh
Binskot, the Quran, the Sunnah, according to the Salaf, Abdul Wahhab, the
Quran, the Sunnah, the Salaf,
Ahlus Sunnah
wal Jama'ah,
Bukhari, may God bless
you. Evil doesn't mean you
calling and speaking out leaders openly
because that goes.
Hadiths of the Chosen One, peace and blessings be upon him.
God is
Great. They seek help from the dead.
From everything about dancing, mashallah.
He becomes the
heil and please do not mix between two
things here that doesn't mean because if you do evil you know allow to be the evil
allowed to forbid the evil you still
allow none of us perfect including
myself I have my own mistakes and my own
sin that doesn't mean I should not enjoy
good and forb the evil may God bless
you all so my dear brothers may God
bless
you spreading the mistakes of the leader
or spreading the sins and disobedience
that is occur countries without
forbiding it or without exposing it
accord to that is the way of
the spread
Oranziak, my brother
Oran and Hanan, God willing,
what a shirt  God willing, Salafism, God willing. For this reason, it is
necessary to differentiate
reality and
media sites  Social
media
onioned the news
and our countenances. May Allah bless you
all. So now, just to conclude, my brothers
and sisters, may Allah bless you all from those who are
watching how to forbid evil if the
leader is doing it. My uncle,
the Quran, the Sunnah, the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, hadith, Sahih
Bukhari,
Muslim, whoever
saw the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, praise be to Allah.
[Music] My
good brother, Allah does not burden a soul beyond
its capacity. The hypocrite, the hypocrites. [
Laughter]
Love, the way of Ahlus Sunnah
wal Jama'ah, the people of
innovation. We ask Allah for safety and well-being. The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
Time
will be
normal. Allah,
Hussein, peace be upon him, the Companions, all of them,
peace be upon them, Ibn
Taymiyyah,
the Companions, Hussein,
Iraq, Hajjaj.
[Music] Ibn, people were
more
than
Algeria in Somalia in
[Music]
Libya,
so we can see because there is no
goodness by him, peace and blessings be upon him.
Allah,
Shari'ah, Shari'ah,
Shari'ah. We seek refuge in Allah from the deceivers. How does he
mean by everything like that? He doesn't mean he's not ruling
by nothing, but
the point here is he said they are
oppressed. He is the most
correct book of the people of
[Applause]
Sunnah, Allah.
Glory be to Him, and may God be glorified and exalted. On the authority of
Adi ibn Hatim, God is the Greatest. Ahlus Sunnah, Hadith, Kharijites, News, Paper, Jazeera, Baby, Seed, Fox News,
Praise be to God, Ahlus Sunnah wal Jama'ah. Adi
ibn Hatim said, "We said, 'O Messenger of God, we will answer God. We do
not ask you about obedience to the pious.'"
[Music]
[Applause]
Fear God and listen and obey God as you have been told.
How you are going to be a leader will be like you. Leaders by the way, they are not from us, so check yourself. How are you raising children? Are you raising children to pray on time? I am raising my children to pray on time, to music, to dance, to haram. Then why are these leaders not like you? May God bless them.
God will never change the state of people until they change themselves. Come and see
how many
people pray. Go and see if they bring a singer, even a Muslim singer. In countries, there are many people.
Then reflect and
say, "God will never oppress
creation." Muhammad and his family and companions, all of them, and grant them abundant peace.